to cut you off for a moment or two we'll
be back with you in a moment sorry greg
because
um florida the crucial state
of florida i think people had worked it
out already given the scenes of
celebration we've seen amongst the
republicans there but we can now project
that
donald trump will win florida and quite
comfortably given how
narrow florida normally is that's a
bigger margin if it stays that way still
four percent of the vote to count if it
stays that way that's a bigger margin
than he won by
in 2016 against hillary clinton 51.2
for donald trump 47.8 for
joe biden there 5.2 million or so for
joe biden 5.6
for donald trump and uh just cordelia
lynch is
with me here and of course reported
extensively in travel extensively in
florida over the years and during the
course of this
campaign it seems a long time ago now
that
the democrats had some pretty solid
hopes there
didn't they they did have some solid
hopes you know they thought
that a changed electorate was going to
potentially deliver big leads i mean
they were
very very reticent to use the landslide
word
but they would have hoped i think at
this stage to have
some kind of major reversal of fortunes
they haven't yet gone got that but let's
see where arizona takes us
you know i've been to florida a lot i
think what is interesting
is quite mixed really uh we looked at
the
elderly vote places like sumpter county
home to the villages the largest
retirement community in the united
states
where a lot of people ride golf carts
and there were signs for the first time
ever of
you know lots of democrat golf carts not
your your typical
trumpian republican ones but
that's small numbers you know we're not
talking about
massive changes here which is kind of
what joe biden needed to push him
over the edge in florida an increased
turnout there as well i know i'm just
doing maths in my head so
i said there i think by recall hillary
clinton lost by just over one percent or
something it was a hundred and twelve
thousand votes and
look at those vote totals there well
donald trump's increase
and you know why he got an absolute
shellacking in places like miami-dade
joe biden he hasn't been able to expand
in the way that hillary clinton was
successful with
latino voters there that